vous étonner mais bravo libération c'est
pas mon genre de le dire habituellement
mais bravo libération j'ai longtemps lui
libération quand libération était de
gauche avant qu'elle ne devienne journal
de bernard tapie 2d d'yves montand de
s'ignorer de vive la crise de la
tournant de la rigueur de 83 etc
et là d'un seul coup on retrouve
effectivement un grand journal qui fait
vraiment un travail de journalisme et
qui fait pour le coup un travail de
gauche pour moi c'est à dire
effectivement de dire regardez ce qui a
lieu c'est regarder le réel il ya peu de
gens qui à gauche je regarde le réel
cette couverture de libération j'ai
trouvé très bonne très intéressant très
belle le travail les libérations très
intéressant aussi sur ce sujet parce
qu'ils disent quelque chose que qui a
lieu c'est le réel moi j'entends les
gens me dire ça
les vrais amis de gauche qui me disent
moi c'est fini moi ya très longtemps
j'ai dit mais vous êtes des idiots
utiles du libéralisme dont vous on vous
met marine le pen devant le nez et vous
finissez toujours par voter le soir du
premier tour pour un président de la
république qui de toute façon défendre à
maastricht et des maastricht ça y est
les gens ont compris ils ont compris le
mécanisme ils ont compris qu'on leur
mente et sarkozy vient d'être condamnée
mais on s'en fout de cette condamnation
ce qui m'intéresserait c'est que sarkozy
soit condamné pour avoir mis à la
poubelle le référendum des français en
2005 le traité constitutionnel que les
français refusent
quand en 2008 il devient le traité de
lisbonne et que l'on inflige au peuple
français qui avait dit non 1 oui que
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
concocte on se dit mais line un procès
affaire est un coup d'état
ici à ce moment là c'est bien que
libération se soucie de ce dossier là
s'en empare réfléchissent à cette
question c'est une question vraiment
d'actualité et moi ce qui m'étonne c'est
que les gens et puis imaginez que que
libération souhaité que que marine le
pen soit élu c'est pas possible c'est
pas dans l'adn de libération donc ce qui
est plutôt dans l'adn d'un libération
des deux
d'une gauche qui avait ma faveur à cette
époque là enfin qui tient toujours ma
faveur c'est effectivement de dire
attention réelle regardez le réel si
vous voulez honorer votre idéal fait le
à partir du réel mais ne dites pas que
leur elle n'a pas eu lieu
[Musique]